hey league of legal where does skill end
and chance begin when it comes to
gambling matt i am so glad you asked
because every state has different laws
on this most states use what's called
the dominant factor test it determines
whether something is luck or skill is it
about luck or predominantly about skill
and there are four subtests is the
contest impossible to win without skill
does the average player have enough
skill to participate in the game does
skill determine the actual result of the
game not simply an aspect of it and are
participants aware of the skill and
criteria that will be used to determine
the winner and i regret to inform you
that states are all over the map on this
some states say that games like 3 card
monty video games that award free
replays and puzzle games are games of
skill but generally they agree that
games like bingo or dice are completely
about luck and have no skill involved
and then when it comes to games like
pinball and poker well
some states say they're games of chance
and some say they are games of skill so
it depends but that's just a theory a
legal theory